police outnumber the public on the
streets of Rome checkpoints anyone
passing needs a permit and a reason why
enforcement appears calm and compliant
but this is only day two of at least 24
and the cracks are appearing already
more my sister is dead in her bed says
Gomorrah actor Luca Franzese posting
this video with his sister's body behind
him after she reportedly died of kovat
19 more than 24 hours after her death he
claims he's had no help authorities
this.q for a supermarket show italians
are taking the lockdown rules seriously
now a 1 metre separation in public
spaces keeping people apart is an
essential measure to save lives and
precious Hospital space the director of
intensive care for Lombardi the
worst-hit region describes the pressure
knowing what you know now what would be
your message to other countries other
health care systems get ready because
when it starts then it's again like an
explosion the Prime Minister today
announced a 25 billion euro fund to
spend on this crisis but it's already
costing the country hugely rose Trevi
Fountain is one of Italy's most famous
sites now virtually deserted anyone
passing checked for a permit
and the government isn't ruling out even
tougher measures than this at the moment
people even simply stopping in the
street and made to move on businesses
like restaurants and cafes are allowed
to open until 6:00 p.m. but they could
be closed altogether along with public
transport this is simply the beginning
of how limited life could get the head
of the country's emergency planning
admits its leap acted too late these
measures they come slowly because all
the country have to be somehow brought
to this kind of measure is the lockdown
going to be extended the lockdown will
will stay as long as it is not necessary
one of the first red zones to be locked
down is showing promise in containing
the virus spread but as numbers surged
across the country as a fear this
lockdown could get tougher and longer